you want to reduce your big fat booty
find a club that's not as snooty that's
because Equinox offers this solution go
somewhere else with your New Year's
resolution
Equinox AKA The Planet Fitness for
douchebags
is making headlines for preventing
people from signing up on January 1st
which I believe was Sunday I can't
remember anyone who has tried was met
with the message you are not a New
Year's resolution your life doesn't
start at the beginning of the year and
that's not what being part of Equinox is
about fine I'm taking my business to
Fuddruckers
the campaign is called we don't speak
January proving that the copywriter once
worked for John Federman
it's a stark contrast to the slogan at
Gold's Gym which is sign up now and the
first injections are free
[Laughter]
basically Equinox wanted to discourage
certain people from joining those who
spend all of December becoming fat
drunks and then join a gym in January
and work out there three or four times
before getting too lazy to go or even to
make a phone call to cancel the
membership I think I have a photo of
that
anyway
but this makes no sense the people who
pay memberships but don't go are the
perfect member to have more money and
less work for you in any case having to
wait one day to sign up for equinox
probably isn't the biggest barrier it's
in fact that the membership costs
hundreds of dollars a month and you're
not even allowed to live there
bad news for you Brian yep so cat um do
you go to Equinox no
you act like I asked you if you ever eat
poop
why would I the only reason people go to
Equinox is so they can work out with
other people who oh I go to eggnogs we
go to just like no absolutely not I
wouldn't go and it's just dumb it's just
people just go there to feel better than
other people good and then this fit
their brand it does I was getting it no
it absolutely does it's like it's like
Oh wait we're just discovering this is
an elitist brand yeah they charge like
almost 400 a month and uh running is
free yeah and there's like workout
videos you can do on the computer on the
internet I do that yeah it's from
Heloise
I don't get any of your reference
that was a great reference was it Eloise
Brian I know what you mean yeah I don't
really go for those tits but you know I
think it's a good point you you're not
into working out the Jane Fonda
videotape still work yeah uh still
effective everyone got hurt and injured
by the way Jane Fonda put on her
headband and hurt America pouring that
later for your spin-off series but I
would say this uh Craig oh wait do I
show you keep going keep going uh I used
to sell memberships I was doing stand-up
for a while and they thought you better
get a day job and a good one so um I was
selling memberships and if they told me
January you couldn't sell memberships
everyone would resign yeah the only time
you make any money no that's this is a
disaster for those people in sales that
usually work solid commission yeah wow
Jamie what do you make of this do you
work I was going to ask you if you
worked out but clearly you don't yeah
um I don't this is that's it's 385 or
something a month a month yeah for real
do you know at Planet Fitness it's it's
like night for 19 a month you cannot
work out and this one's like 400 to not
work out
I went there once on a guest pass with a
friend of mine that has like a little
bit of cash and it is correct it's like
well they don't even have a row machine
they have a yacht and you just
and then um
some of these guys have tons of money
like this one guy wanted me to come over
to see his golden shower and I go that
is
too expensive somebody's wealthy yeah
how do they make that how do they do
that I don't know
yet I still go
KT have you ever been doing Equinox I
used to belong to it and then the
pandemic I stopped going and I never got
I'm one of the people they lost
I'm over 70. that's an inappropriate
question
you go to it's a gym I think it was
absolutely brilliant marketing really
you think so totally because so how many
people were going to sign up on January
1st a lot a lot two thousand yeah maybe
five thousand and it's on a Sunday but
yeah and it was on a Sunday people were
still recovering but it was a one day
thing right look at the next thing to
sign up and you could pay your 500 a
month but so what did they get for this
they got National publicity everybody's
talking about Equinox Gym right and I
think it was just simply a lot of free
publicity it was quite brilliant because
if you're gonna spend that kind of money
on January 1st you're still committed to
spending that much money on January 2nd
do you think Planet Hollywood's colors
are too bright you know I was just
thinking about that right they're like
purple and yellow right I mean well you
said
he's working ahead
I'm thinking Planet uh Planet Fitness
you know that's great
laughs
up next no juice left no juice out of
that one instead of a weekend that
sleazy Grooms want to take it easy hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else